what is it about Joe and his films that
are so intriguing as because they're so
natural
they're very natural I love Greta Gerwig
performances I think I mean I knew she
was a star the first time I saw her
which was in bag head I didn't see her
first in Joe's films but and so that
makes it fun to watch is when you're
seeing someone and you're like you're
awesome
you're just a wonderful talent that's
always makes things fun to watch but
with Joe's films yeah I think you know
we're about the same age and
while there are certain things that he's
shown on screen that I have never seen
before or since you know I can think of
a few shots right now from his very
first film you know and and I still
haven't seen them in any one else's
films you know since but I don't know I
think there's a rawness where you don't
know what's coming next
there's there's an unpredictability
because they're improv you know a lot of
times
there's an authenticity I think that I
that I enjoy watching and and also he
deals with subjects that I've not seen
people deal with the one that comes to
mind is I just saw two like a year ago
it was an AFI they buy
Oh
it was this great film of our history it
was our history is maybe not for
everyone if you've seen that you might
know why but
if you're an actor you may have
experienced that line that can get
crossed or you if you have actor friends
you've heard about the line that can get
crossed when two people work together
and the intimacy of acting together can
breed intimacy in real life and I've
never seen a film about that there may
be another film about that but I've
never seen it until I saw Joe's film art
history and I was like yeah that's how
it is that's that's how it can be you
know and I was I don't know so I guess I
appreciate the truth that I see in in
his films sometimes even though I I know
not everyone's into them and that's fine
but but some sometimes those are you
know
you